curse of the buzzsaw came in swirling
oceans 275 million years ago lived one
of the top predators of its time
if you look over it was like a mutant
creature from a horror movie it looks
like a shark with a terrifying buzzsaw
in its job
it's bike was as strong as a modern
crocodiles how could such a bizarre job
work the angle of its mouth was bigger
than a great white shark teeth pushed
the prey deep inside the jagged spiral
was forced into a notch in the upper jaw
prey was sliced into no less frightening
was its size twice as long as a great
white it had fewer fins and a narrower
body don't get close to these blades
they're four inches long and angled
backwards new teeth pushed older ones
deep into the whirling rotations in the
job teen monsters had two rotations
adults had four circles of flesh ripping
Chalmers more than 150 of the fossils
have been found the odd shape mystified
scientists for over a century
the Gila Capri on went extinct long ago
but beware the curse of the buzzsaw
killer it's always wise to play it safe
in the water
[Music]
you
[Music]